good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is just go for it over to you Jack ma ma
made it into college on his third try
and became an English teacher with no
computing or engineering background
he's an unlikely tech Titan but he says
he was captivated by the internet from
the moment he first saw it in 1995 when
he came to the US as a translator I
never touched keyboard before I never
using computer before and I say what is
internet he's a jack you know such
whatever you want on the Internet
how can I search what is such me is it
just the type I said I don't want to
type computer is so expensive in China I
don't want to destroy it he said it's
not a bomb just the type so I tapped the
first to work of beer at that time very
slow come out the American beer Japan
beer in the German beer but no China
beer so I was curious and it was type of
China no China no datum came back to
Hangzhou worth a $1 in my pocket scared
worried and I came back and I said I
want to do something called Internet
Jack store reminds me of Howard Schultz
who started Starbucks and he was on his
trip family vacation to Milan and Italy
and he saw how Italians love the coffee
shops it was their third home they hung
out there they spend a lot of time there
and he looked to North America and saw
the Dunkin Donuts of the world where
it's like in and out cheap coffee just
grab it and go and he wanted to create
that atmosphere take it from Italy and
bring it back to North America just like
Jack did for the internet and so like
what happens when you have this idea
when you have this great idea that
you've come up with or you've modeled
success somewhere else and said it works
here I want to bring it here like what
happens to you when you have these ideas
do you execute on them do you try
you go for that do you do it you you get
answers we just kind of sit on it here's
what a lot of people do is they sit on
it a lot of people they brainstorm when
you come up with tons of ideas in your
head and that's great and that's really
fulfilling and it gets the endorphins
going you said imagine in the future
world in this great future business but
you have to actually do something about
it right and it doesn't mean you have to
quit your job now saying go all-in quit
your job you know take out a huge
mortgage or a huge loan and bet your
entire future on this one thing working
out I don't think you need to do that
but I do think you need to do something
I do think you need to take some kind of
action because whenever you have an idea
you also have to recognize that there's
a limited window of time to make that
happen it's not going to be around for
you forever you have a limited amount of
time to make that opportunity happen
before that window shuts closed or
somebody else goes and does it and so
when you find that thing that you know
you want to try that you know you want
to do you think it's gonna really work
you have to go for it you've got to do
you've got to jump through the window
before it closes on you because the
alternative is you live the rest of your
life with regret I look at my youtube
channel as an example we are hitting it
hard right now right now is my window
I'm having a fantastic window right now
right it's not to be bold or boastful or
building myself up like this is my
moment right now you know I was on
YouTube a while ago I don't know when I
started eight nine years ago something
like that maybe less and I had some
videos and I tested and I tried and it
was okay and I slowly got more and more
committed to it and then I saw the
opening like this is this is the moment
right now it just combines everything
that works well for me versus other
opportunities other platforms out there
right video I love video being able to
DJ content from different celebrities
and entrepreneurs and famous faces being
able to be an expert in the YouTube
space and be able to teach some of these
thought leaders in business about
YouTube and form a lot of collaborations
and partnerships to use their content to
make the top tens it's it's just a
moment in time for me right now where
things are hitting it really hard I have
the opportunity to do really really
really really really well and so it's my
responsibility to do so if I don't then
I'm letting myself down I'm letting you
guys
I have nobody else to blame somebody
else if I stop doing this somebody else
you would pick up the mantle and go out
and do it and they would go off and have
a big impact I can't sit back and say
that guy stole my idea and crushed it
which happens so often like you have an
idea you don't do anything with it
somebody else takes the idea without
talking to you they just go out and do
it on their own and then say that guy
made millions off of my idea well no
like that was their idea you just didn't
do anything about it you got to take
that action and so right now is my
window to do this YouTube may not be
around forever it won't you know will
YouTube still be like this in five years
in ten years maybe maybe not so I've got
this window that fits really really
really well for me right now and so I
have to jump through it as fast as I can
with the resources that I have to get as
much out of it and to give as much into
it as well
and so you're going to have these
moments where you have absolute clarity
like this is what I want to do you can
have a lot of moments we have no idea
what to do alright when you don't know
what to do then you've got to experiment
and try things and say yes like you
won't figure out what you want to do by
sitting on the couch all day you got to
get out and say yes and try things and
most of those things won't work and
that's okay you're experimenting so
that's where you are just keep saying
yes keep experimenting try things at
least once until you find a thing that
you wanted to go do again and do again
and do again and do again but if you're
at that moment where you know what you
want to do we found that clarity you've
done all the testing this is the path
for you you have that figured out
recognize that that will not be
available to you forever you've got to
do something right now to hone in on
those skills and go and execute because
for life reasons or market conditions or
a whole bunch of other reasons that
window will eventually closed down on
you whether it's in five weeks five
months five years it's going to close
down on you
and so if you have that moment of
clarity you owe it to yourself you owe
it to your family you owe it to your
community you into the world to run as
fast as you can with the resources that
you have with the resourceful nnessee
you have inside you to take that idea
from inside you and gift it to the world
because otherwise you'll regret it for
the rest of your life so the question
today is I'm curious do you have that
clarity do you know the path like this
is what you want to do and get it
accomplished or are you still wandering
he's still trying to figure it out
either one is fine because on your
trajectory in life you'll go through
both phases of uncertainty and certainty
so I'm just curious where are you right
now
certainty I know what I want to do
exactly or uncertainty I'm still trying
to figure things out leaving down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Stanley Pham Stanley thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book your one word it really really
means a lot to me and I hope you're
enjoying the read thank you guys again
for watching I hope you have an amazing
day I believe in you I hope we continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an espresso
[Music]
and it was you regularly see the failure
propels you are there any assisted in
your past truly where you couldn't get
over it and why by the way by the way
that's the same answer for everybody in
this room that's what humans are good at
we all fail we've all failed like there
by I my parents haven't been killed my
child I mean there's people that have
their children die like could you
imagine like I feel like I'm like listen
unfortunately or fortunately depends on
how one wants to look at it I'm a pretty
optimistic guy I lost three of my four
grandparents before I was really before
I knew them two before I was born in one
very early on like so you know it's easy
for me to be happy I am like in the
right order the health and well-being of
my family and there's nothing even
remotely close to that not even you
would not even remotely
people have gotten three much worse this
is why I'm trying to recall our
grandparents and our great-grandparents
people were persecuted and killed like I
just we do not have real headaches you
know I don't know why I have this highly
emotional and then completely
unemotional part of me but I mix them
together to create the balance and
that's what works for me so of course
there's nothing that I couldn't get
upfront like every other human ever
besides somebody who now lives in some
weird cave that we don't know about you
know what I mean we were strong as we're
just being sold that we're not because
there's a lot of money a lot of money
and telling us that we're not pretty
enough thin enough smart enough good
enough that I want to tell you your task
oh dude I was raised to think that there
was I couldn't do anything
you know don't don't get your hopes up
okay
I remember one day I remember one time I
was asked and drowning my mother you
know what I might want to be I said gee
I really like sports may like be a
sports announcer she goes you're not
special you're not gonna be a sports you
know she wanted me to be a mailman
really that was her dream yes you want
to take the simple service test and
become a mailman because you know they
did you get the security and you always
have a paycheck and a pension so being
that being a comedian didn't occur to me
then I got out of college and my
friend's wife kept saying you know
you're funny
why aren't you doing stand-up comedy
because I was floundering so I went to
watch a night of comedy as I'm watching
it I'm going Jesus I think you know what
I think I couldn't do this and in the
middle of the show I walk up to bud
Friedman who's the manager of the club
the owner of the club and I say uh
I'd like to go on yeah like how insane
is that I want to go on I have nothing
okay I've never been on a stage I want
to go on thank God
he said who are you
no of course not you can't go on
you got a audition okay so then I wrote
some material and I started trying to do
it
none of this could possibly happen with
our Ariel Reichman and without his basic
abhorrence of conventional wisdom in
many respects he and you both share an
extraordinary common concept and that is
neither one of you knew what you
couldn't do and by virtue of not knowing
what you can't do you just try and do it
and that's what entrepreneurship is all
about you you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or so it would be like
a little beacon hey believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details